beautiful sunday afternoon here in south
florida and great to see pablo lopez
will tow the slab one final time here in
2021
chopped left side and that'll get past
marrero at third herrera takes a turn he
goes towards second miller's throw is
there waiting for him and herrera takes
a little tumble and bryce harper
wow shaved it all off today
live drive out to left center field
that's going to be it for a base set
goodbye sierra is going to cut it off
his throw goes to second base harper on
his way to second slides in safely that
is double number 42 for brights harper
is this the phillies in a nutshell if
they don't score here three hits in the
inning one walk and they might not score
swing and a miss strike three
welcome back pablo acting manager miguel
rojas this is his lineup top to bottom
he drew it up and he's been working on
it for a couple of days we understand
basic valley falter for belly falter
this is his first major league start
and a base hit on the final day of the
regular season that one's going to roll
all the way to the wall miller is racing
around third he's going to score alvarez
headed toward third here's the throw
it's cut off an rbi triple for eddie
alvarez one nothing marlins and now
looking for even more here's jazz
he might even take an rbi single right
here yeah that'll work base hit for jazz
alvarez scores in the marlins have a two
to nothing league
freddy galvez will lead it off freddie
223 with four homers and 13 runs batted
in in a philly's uniform
oh he may not have gotten out of out in
front of that one he shoots it to deep
right field and it's gone off the second
deck
galvez's fifth home run into phil's
uniform and he's made this a 2-1 game
well i think that's going to be it
biggie's making his way out there now
this was not about results this was all
about seeing the velocity seeing the
smile seeing that everything is okay and
it is
high chopper boom just out of his reach
fortes will head to third
mccutcheon's got no play there
and magneris sierra
with a bouncer over bowm first and third
that'll bring up stephen oaker okad
enter got the last out of the top of
this inning
and grounds one to deedy will take it
himself
and get the double play run scores
anyway
now there's ball four 100 walks for
bryce harper and it just adds to what
has been an unbelievable season for
bryce that includes 100 runs 40 doubles
30 home runs at 100 walks i mean look at
the list that he is on three to one ball
game two outs here in the third inning
and a high fly ball to left it's deep
miller's going back to the fence he
jumps he can't get it it's gone
it's a two-run home run it ties the game
up at three
and for andrew mccutchen it's his 27th
homer of the year
swag and a miss he got a
wicked movement alvarado
is able to get through this third get a
couple strikeouts his season may be done
for the phillies oh duba herrera swings
at the first one sends one out to center
and mags makes the play on the line
drive so one two three inning for zach
thompson so base runner here in the
fourth inning and that brings fortes to
the plate
it's a fly ball it's pretty well hit out
to left field and a home run for nick
fortes
a bright spot for the marlins offense in
september
now into october with a two-run home run
two balls two strikes in the pitch swing
and a miss he got him it gets away
chisholm's gonna walk away now he's
hustling to first andrew fires to first
in time and hector nearest with 520
career strikeouts is now the all-time
leader in strikeouts for a relief
pitcher in philadelphia philly's history
that one's pulled out to right it's hit
pretty well
and sierra and de la cruz converge and
neither is able to get it indeed he'll
get to second base
marlins get through this
fifth inning
with the lead
the arrival of sir anthony dominguez
could be
part of the last day storylines
swinging a miss and sir anthony
dominguez gets a strikeout
ground ball to shortstop freddie galvez
and a one two three
sixth inning
two pitch from blyer
swinging to miss
and a ground ball alvarez has it
and makes the play that's gonna do it
for the phillies in the seventh richard
bleyer gets that era to sub three
two at two out of the pitch
swing and a miss he went around it was
nowhere near it
two outs here at the bottom of the
seventh
swing and a miss kennedy gets a
strikeout back-to-back case
it's a one two three seventh inning
we're on to the eighth inning but score
some runes movies down two
the bender delivers and the pitch is
bunted and uh out to get it fortis goes
into a slide couldn't grab it and
jankowski with a perfect front base hit
runner goes pitch high throw to second
he does get it
other way for brad miller that's it for
a basic jankowski streaming home
and he'll score miller stops at first
it's a one-run game
oh i think he's small
i think he
you
did
have to throw it to first that's a dead
ball yeah alvarez got to go back to
second
change up by medina and just get chasing
into de la cruz
ground ball over to first jt's got it
he'll take it to the back diaz will
stroll slowly up the line we are heading
to the ninth inning dylan florrow his
68th outing of the year
looking for another save to close out
the season and
hopefully get the marlins the season
series win against the phillies or ball
in two strikes to nap swing and a miss
for strike three
in the air center field coming in sierra
makes the catch two away
and this one's out to center sierra
closing in on it
it's a marlins win
in game 162 the marlins hold off the
phillies
and what has been
an up and down season for the marlins
they finish on a high note